Цей закинутий завод на околиці Києва цієї суботи - імпровізований полігон для вишколу бійців територіальної оборони.
Більшість із них - резервісти-контрактники 130 батальйону тероборони Солом'янського району столиці.
Бійці вчаться патрулювати місцевість, штурмувати та зачищати будівлі.
Зброя - автомати для гри в страйкбол. Стріляють пластиковими кульками.
Ми передовий загін ворога виявили, частину знищили, щонайменше двоє відступили.
Двох знищили, двох втратили.
Це були молоді та недосвідчені, вони зробили помилку - не прикривали один одного, висунулися одночасно.
Денис Семирог-Орлик у повсякденному житті працює архітектором.
Від початку війни допомагає військовим як волонтер.
Контракт із батальйоном тероборони підписав у 2018 році.
І хоча навіть не проходив строкової служби, вже отримав звання старшого солдата і став командиром відділення.
Чоловік також заснував громадську організацію "Територіальна оборона столиці",
яка допомагає проводити вишколи і популяризувати тероборону.
Ми готуємося до опору.
Якщо буде агресія - і не тільки на Донбасі, але і з інших напрямків, -
по виклику ми повинні піднятися і зайняти певні позиції, які ми маємо боронити.
У нас до кордону тут не так вже й далеко.
Якщо ворог буде знати, що рівномірно по всій території України буде спротив, то він сюди не сунеться.
Це, мені здається, краще за ядерну зброю.
Так, вони можуть прорвати оборону і пройти, але в тилу, на шляхах - всюди буде спротив.
Як і Денис, більшість бійців батальйону раніше не займалися військовою справою.
На вишколах можна зустріти представників найрізноманітніших професій - від водія до науковця, чоловіків та жінок.
Мар'яна Жагло - маркетолог. Контракт із батальйоном підписала у 50 років.
У підрозділ Мар'яну привів її фітнес-тренер - біженець з Донбасу.
Нині спортзал вже відійшов на другий план - такі заняття дають змогу тримати себе у гарній фізичній формі.
Потім, якщо щось трапиться, я буду до цього готова.
У мене є діти, і я не хочу, щоб вони постраждали, як той хлопець, який мене сюди привів.
Переселенець з Донецька Дмитро Терновський, який запросив Мар'яну у батальйон, працює тренером та реабілітологом.
Як волонтер допомагає військовим відновлюватися після фронту.
Завдяки медичній освіті Дмитро отримав посаду бойового медика роти.
А через донецьку прописку - позивний "Сєпар".
Сам себе жартома називає "жертвою російського імперіалізму".
Контракт я підписав рік тому, а також вступив у Військовий інститут телекомунікацій та інформатизації - навчаюся на офіцера запасу.
Кожна година, проведена тут на вишколі, прямо пропорційна секундам виживання у бою.
Якщо непідготовлений піхотинець у бою виживає 3-5 хвилин, то це дозволить протриматися на декілька секунд довше.
У нас є тактична підготовка, тактична медицина, спеціальна фізична підготовка.
Про важливість навіть такої базової підготовки не з чуток знає Артем Сохань.
Він працює провізором, але має бойовий досвід - воював на Донбасі, отримав поранення.
Артем - старший лейтенант, командир роти.
Коли я пішов добровольцем, у мене не було жодної підготовки.
Привезли, дали автомат і відразу поїхали.
Зараз хлопці, які хоча б раз на місяць приходять, вони розуміють, що і як треба робити - як взагалі тримати зброю.
Якби хоча б половина з того, що є зараз, було у 2014, втрати були б набагато меншими і було б набагато легше.
Війська територіальної оборони існують у багатьох країнах світу.
Серед переваг таких підрозділів - військові вишколи без відриву від роботи, що дозволяє державі економити кошти,
а також можливість швидко мобілізувати значний резерв навчених бійців у випадку війни.
У Польщі такі резервні формування почали створювати після військової агресії Росії на Донбасі.
В Україні війська тероборони існують багато років і налічують 25 бригад, що складаються з батальйонів.
Нині у військах територіальної оборони - 8000 тисяч резервістів, які підписали контракт.
А загалом, за даними командування, до тероборони у разі потреби можуть бути залучені понад 350 тисяч осіб.
Утім, не всі підрозділи тренуються ефективно, а офіційних вишколів - недостатньо, вважають бійці та командири.
Учасники тероборони розповідають, що стрільби з бойовою зброєю - так звані "стрілецькі дні" -
проводяться раз на місяць, а бійцям видають лише по 30 патронів.
До того ж, навіть ці тренування відвідують далеко не всі.
Люди зобов'язані приходити тільки на збори, які проводяться підрозділом - збирають батальйон чи бригаду.
Ці збори за законодавством - раз на рік, від одного тижня до 30 днів.
Стрілецькі дні - це збори одного дня за бажанням. Вони не оплачуються.
Приходять люди, які можуть прийти, які не працюють у цей день і мають бажання займатися.
Ми проводимо не тільки офіційні заняття - люди бачать, що у нас відбувається більше вишколів і до нас більше людей приходять - активних патріотів.
Ми з начальником штабу є інструкторами, ми проводимо заняття, а також інструктори з громадської організації.
Інструктори з громадської організації - це полковник і майор.
Зарплату контрактники не отримують, але їм компенсують час перебування на зборах.
Також за ними зберігається робоче місце.
Форму отримали не всі - більшість бійців одяг та амуніцію для вишколів вихідного дня придбали власним коштом.
Повний комплект може коштувати понад 30 000 гривень.
Багато хто придбав і власну зброю - формально мисливська, вона мало відрізняється від бойової.
З нею тренуються у тирі. Знову-таки - патрони купують самі.
Більш глобальна проблема - відсутність єдиного закону, який би детально врегулював завдання і організацію тероборони.
Форма насправді - це не головне.
Треба більше - нам потрібні пункти постійної дислокації, нам потрібно майно, нам потрібна техніка.
Нам потрібні навчальні центри, де ми могли б займатися, а не на оцих руїнах.
Ми знаходимось сім років у стані війни - щось дуже довго буксують із прийняттям закону про територіальну оборону, яка нам просто необхідна.
Наразі система територіальної оборони регулюється однією зі статей закону "Про оборону України" -
це лише декілька абзаців - та указом президента.
Наприкінці минулого року у Верховну Раду було внесено законопроєкт,
розроблений за участі військових експертів та громадських організацій, які займаються вишколами.
Документ передбачає створення резерву територіальної оборони чисельністю до 390 000 осіб,
низку пільг та компенсацій для контрактників, а також детально регламентує завдання і структуру цих військ.
Крім того, над законодавчим врегулюванням працює міжвідомча група, яку очолює перший заступник секретаря РНБО Михайло Коваль.
Тож незабаром тероборона, яка нині існує переважно завдяки ентузіазму її учасників та командирів,
зможе стати повноцінним компонентом захисту держави - як у Польщі та Естонії.